good morning believe nation today's
message is compromised over to you Ryan
Gosling
I think compromises is is integral to
the creative process and it's it's it's
more about finding a way to see those
find a way to make those compromises
into you know opportunities and and not
see them as obstacles otherwise you can
get really stuck yeah it says I think
that's the only way to keep moving
forward and being creative so this is an
interesting message for this channel
because so often people are coming in
saying go for it never give up go push
harder and he was a message saying
compromise and I think it's actually
when you look at the most successful
entrepreneurs and the most successful
leaders it's both it's the genius at the
end you will see that the most
successful leaders are insanely stubborn
for the why but insanely flexible about
that and this is where a lot of
entrepreneurs will fall short because
you're so obsessed about doing this
thing in a particular way that it may
not work out then chances are it won't
chances are that product that you want
to put out people may not like the
design meaning they may not like the
functionality may not work exactly as
you thought it would and you need to
tweak it you need to change it you need
to listen you need to compromise but
what you won't compromise is the big
vision which you won't compromise on is
your one word your value right like this
is what you stand for and that's the
line in the sand and you're not gonna go
over it where I think most people are
stubborn about small things I think most
people are stubborn about the wrong
things I think most people are so
stubborn that they hold themselves back
because they're not willing to
compromise to get to the big goal which
you need to have
is the ego to believe that you can do
the big thing the confidence and the
boldness to grow it and chase that big
dream and then at the same side the
humbleness for the cause you can do this
big thing you're confident you have the
ego to do it but the humbleness to do
anything needed to go out and do it
maybe that means you have to sweep the
floors anything the great leaders will
do anything to move their cause forward
as long as it falls within you know the
lines of who they are right but nothing
is beneath them they'll get on the
assembly line and start making products
that they need to they'll make the phone
calls if they need to they'll sweep the
floors if they'll need to and so if
you're being stubborn about something
right now I would really challenge you
to think does this actually matter
because the most important thing is
advancing the cause stubbornness around
the why the mission the cause and
flexibility around the execution and how
to do it it's my advice what do you
think I want to know in your life in
your business what is non-negotiable
what are you not willing to compromise
on I'm curious leave in the comments
below I want to see your answers I just
want to give a big shout out to Jeff
Jeff thank you so much you're picked up
a copy of my book your one word it
really really really means a lot to me
and appreciate the support thank you
guys for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso
what's that believe nation to add some
more perspective on this idea of
compromising we're gonna put a couple
more bonus clips that I hope you'll
enjoy I have no education I had no high
school diploma I didn't even have a GED
I quit high school halfway through grade
10 I didn't have a lot of options that
would be a dishwasher or a waiter
custodial work of some sort so I decided
I might as well go and do something
creative I decided to go to the comedy
store the Laugh Factory in the improv
you know all all of those clubs every
night and make my 25 bucks a pop a set
was my version of him later it was a
compromise I decided to make out of that
came in living color and out of that
came touring
auditoriums 5,000 Cedars was a really
creative time I was able to prove that I
didn't have to be an impressionist that
I had a personality of my own and
however abrasive it might be from time
to time a long story short all of it
came from that compromise from that
deciding to do what I didn't want to do
things you can't do or the things you're
not allowed to do look at the executives
come and say you can't do that whatever
it is it's too expensive you get angry
to get out of your mind about it because
you've been clinging to this concept in
this image that you have of how it
should be done and invariably most times
after that storm has passed and you
actually sit down and go okay we can't
do it that way how can we do it he end
up with something even better than what
was there before
that's the universe that's how it works
just like relationships like everything
the thing that has taken away
and you're clinging to when you're
trying to fix they're trying to secure
it make sure it doesn't go away we think
it your life will be destroyed
everything will be ruined
and it's just the universe going no I
have something better for them I just
have faith sometimes compromise is
actually the way to get to what you want
I have a certain gene in my body that
allows me to understand what someone
else is saying when they say we want to
sell a lot of these things like I don't
see selling a bunch of something as the
opposite of it being interesting or
important or meaningful I've always had
I've always seen it from both sides you
know and it's a really interesting place
that I'm in right now like I you do have
to balance you know if you saw my iTunes
playlist I could I could I don't have a
conversation with anybody at Stereogum
or pitchfork you know but what I do with
Columbia Records as the artist that I am
with the records that I make under the
contract
that I have I'm taking all of my
influences and I'm trying to convert
them into pop music that's my job right
now it's not the only thing I can do and
it's not the only thing I will do but as
long as I'm still trying to make pop
songs I want to play by pop rules you
know III want to listen to top 20 and
figure out what's going on I don't want
to fall behind I'm trying to take all
the elements of music that I love that
I'm well versed in and convert them into
music that a lot of people can get into
I don't know why I do that it's a lot of
people can't a lot of people find the
compromise maddening I see it as another
challenge and I see it as another Talent
you know like the ultimate talent of
restraint all filmmaking is intelligent
compromise that's the whole process we
go through you never have enough I mean
gonna be able to vouch for this no
matter what your budget is you never
have enough time you never have money
that's you you're in the so it's weird
when you're doing
a huge film you're in the same position
you were when you were doing a tiny film
it's you're always and there's a good
reason for that you're always trying to
get as much on screen as you possibly
can and so whatever the the box that's
built for you by the economics of the
project you you're always trying to push
up against those those walls and so you
need help from your team in terms of how
you arrange things and and how you make
that work waking up every morning and
compromising hmm you have this idea this
ideal of what you want to do that day
and you then you know you just
it just gets stripped away and stripped
away and stripped away in stripped away
except for those magnificent moments
when the cast does something that you
couldn't imagine and you go wow mmm that
is really awesome and then you
immediately get a feeling of dread
because you're expecting then as soon as
you say cut that someone will say yeah
we missed the focus there was a boom in
the shot there was an extra in the
background who tripped and fell whatever
that whatever the thing is that ruined
the moment that you may not get back
again